how are you with those Flyers misspelled  by KO by Rory by Mickey by mail by  Nelson by Hannah by test bye-bye Casper  hey what do you think it  a singing competition just think your  neighbor the the grocery store manager  that set that chicken right there  everyone in the city gets a shot at  being a store live on my stage the wrong  land come my lady  come come my lady you're my butterfly  my gosh it hurt but oh my gosh  we'll go okay oh yes I'm fine thank you  how are you talking in her sleep though  answers a lot of things in her sleep  okay hand me the ratchet wrench so I can  fix it but Dad what if she starts sleep  swimming again I'm sure this